you were a CEO for a long time of a
public company were there times when
there was pressure to sacrifice
what is good for the world
um for the bottom line
in order to do it because there were a
lot of times for that I mean I I think
every company faces that today and that
um
I always felt like there's so much
discussion about stakeholder capitalism
right do you just serve a shareholder do
you have multiple
I have always found and I've been very
vocal about that topic that um when I
participated The Business Roundtable
wrote up a new purpose statement that
had multiple stakeholders
I think it's common sense like if you're
going to be 100 years old you only get
there because you actually do at some
time balance all these different
stakeholders in what it is that you do
and short term long term all these
trade-offs and I always say people who
write about it they write about it black
and white but I have to live in a gray
world nothing I've ever done has been in
a black and white World hardly maybe
things of values that I had to answer
but most of it is great and so
um I think back lots of different
decisions
um I think back as you would well
remember you're a student of History IBM
was one of the really The Originators of
the semiconductor industry and certainly
of commercializing the semiconductor
industry great r d and Manufacturing but
it is a game of volume and so when I
came on we were still manufacturing r d
and Manufacturing our own chips we were
losing a lot of money yet here we had to
fight a war on cloud and Ai and so okay
now shareholders would say fine shut it
down okay those chips also power some of
the most important systems that power
these the banks of today if I just shut
it down what would that do and so okay
the answer wasn't just stop it the
answer wasn't just keep putting money
into it the answer was and we had to
kind of sit in an uncomfortable spot
till we found a way I mean it's going to
sound so basic but you as an engineer
understand it
we had to separate it was a very
integrated process of research
development and Manufacturing and you'd
also you'd be perfecting things in
manufacturing and it's these were very
high performance chips
we had to be able to separate those
things we eventually found a way to do
that so that we could
um take the manufacturing elsewhere and
we would maintain the r d it's a I think
it's a great example of the question you
just asked because
there was people would have applaud it
others would have been this was horrible
or we had a financial road map that had
been put in place that said I'll make
this amount of eps by this date there
came a time we couldn't honor it because
we had to invest and so there's a
million of these decisions I I think
most people of their run firms any size
firm they're just one right after
another like that and you're always
making that short and long tension of
what am I giving up well what does that
partnership like with the with the class
because you work with gigantic
businesses and what what's it like
sort of um
really forming a great relationship with
them understanding what their needs are
being service of their in terms of yeah
very simple
honor your promises
and that happens over time I mean in
service of you know which is often why
you could work with competitors because
if you are really in service of you and
you need something it takes two of us to
do it that becomes easier to do because
I really we both care you get what you
needed and so I can remember
um
during one of the times I was on a
European trip and
at the time a lot and this is still true
about views about technology and
National technology Giants and Global
ones and the pros and the cons and
countries want their own national
champions quite obvious I mean if I'm
France or Germany and um there was a lot
of discussion about security and data
and who was getting access to what and I
can remember being in one of the I was
with Chancellor Merkel I had met her
many times she's very well prepared very
well prepared every time as you would
know and
I started to explain all these things
about why how you know how we don't
share data how who it belongs to our
systems never had back doors and she
sort of stopped me
like you're one of the good guys like
stop now
that wasn't about me personally she's
she's talking about a company that's
acted consistent with values for decades
right so to me how you work with those
big kind of clients is you honor your
promises you you say what you do when
you do what you say and you act with
values over a long period of time I and
and that to me people say we're value it
is not a fluffy thing it is not a fluffy
thing it is a
I
I mean if I was starting a company now
I'd spend a lot of time on that and
you know why we do what we do and why
some things are tolerable and something
you know what's your fundamental beliefs
are and uh and many people sort of Zoom
past that stage right it's okay for a
while and never sacrifice that you would
never sacrifice that I don't think you
can so there is a lot of pressure when
you took over as CEO and there was 22
consecutive quarters of Revenue decline
between 2012 and the summer of 2017. so
it was a stressful time Maybe not maybe
you can correct me on that so uh as a
CEO what was it like going through that
time the decisions the tensions in terms
of investing versus uh making a profit
I always felt that that sense of urgency
was so high and even if I was calm on
the outside because you you have
one of the world's largest pensions so
so many people depend on you you have a
huge Workforce they're depending on you
you have clients whose businesses don't
run if you don't perform
Etc and shareholders of course right and
so
but I also am really clear this was
perhaps the largest reinvention IBM ever
had to undertake yes at a board that
understood that
in fact some people some of the
headlines were like this is existential
right I mean nobody gives you a right to
exist forever and there aren't many
texts you're the student of it they are
gone they are all gone and so if we
didn't reinvent ourselves we were going
to be extinct and so
now but you're big and it's like
changing what's that old saying can I
change
um the wheels while the Train's running
or something like that or the engines
while the plane's flying exactly and
that's what you have to do and that took
time and so you know Lex do I wish it
would have been faster absolutely but
the team worked so hard and in my in
that time frame 50 of the portfolio was
changed it's a very large company and
um
if you would also divested 10 billion
dollars of businesses so if you would
look at that growth rate without
divestitures and currency which now
today everyone talks about currency back
then we were the only International guy
um net of divestitures and currency the
growth was flat it's flat great no but
flat for a big transformation I was
really proud of the team for what they
did that is actually pretty miraculous
to have made it through that I have my
little nephew one day and you would see
on TV occasionally when there would be
criticism and you'd say uh you know
Auntie doesn't does that make you mad
when they talk mean yeah and I just
looked at him and I said you know he
says how do you feel I said look I'm
doing what has to be done
and I happen to be the one there and if
you have great conviction and I did
a great conviction I knew it was the
right thing I knew it would be needed
for IBM to live its second century and
so and my successor they have picked up
gone for I mean you go back we did the
acquisition of red hat I mean we had to
find our way on cloud right we were late
to it so we had to find our way and
eventually that led us to hybrid cloud
we did a lot of work with red hat back
in 2017 oh we'd always done a lot of
work with him actually we're one of the
First Investors when they were first
formed
um but that was 2018 you know it took
quite a hit for even you know oh it was
the largest then software acquisition
ever but it is the foundation right of
what is our hybrid Cloud play today and
doing very very well so but I had to
take a short-term hit for that right
short-term hit for a very large 34
billion dollar acquisition uh but it was
for all of us it was the right thing to
do so I think when you get really
centered on you know it's the right
thing to do you just keep going right so
the team had the vision they had the
belief and everything else so don't we
didn't always have exactly the right you
know this wasn't a Straight Arrow but
stay down you know you're right keep
going okay made a mistake you know
there's no bad mistake as long as you
learn from it right and and keep moving
so yes did it take longer but we are the
largest that was there could you maybe
just on a small tangent educate me a
little bit so right hat originally is
Linux open source distribution of Linux
but it's also Consulting well it's it's
a little bit of Consulting but it's
mostly software districts it was mostly
software yeah absolutely absolutely so
but today uh IBM is very much this you
know service most I.T services in the
world has done by IBM there's so many so
many varied uh so basically if you have
issues problems to solve in in business
uh in the software space IBM can help
yes and so in in that my last year uh
our services business we broke it into
two pieces and one piece was spun off
into a company called kindral which is
managed Outsourcing
um keeping things running and they're
off creating their own company what IBM
then retained is really the part I built
with pwcc the big Consulting arm and so
today the IBM of today in 2023 is you
know at least ending 2022 was 30
Consulting and the other 70 would be uh
what would you consider software Cloud
AI so hybrid cloud and AI is the other
and some Hardware obviously still the
Mainframe is modernized Alive and
Kicking and still running some of the
most important things of every Bank you
can think of practically uh in the world
and so that is the IBM of today versus
perhaps you know in red hat is a big
piece and an important part of that
software portfolio and they had some
services with them for implementation
but it wasn't a very a very large part
and it's it's grown by Leaps and Bounds
you know because originally the belief
was everything was going to go to the
public cloud and at least
many people thought that way
we didn't and in fact we I mean we tried
we were cured a public Cloud company we
really tried to work it but what we
found was a lot of the mission critical
work
it it was tuned for Consumer World it
wasn't tuned for the Enterprise so then
time is elapsing here though and you got
to be upscale and we didn't have any
application remember we're not an
application company so it wasn't like we
had an office we didn't have anything
that like pulled things out to the cloud
and so as we looked for what our best
what we really back to who you are we
really know Mission critical work we
know where it lives today and we know
how to make it live on the cloud which
led us down hybrid Cloud you know that
belief that the real world would turn
into there'll be things on traditional
that'll you'll never move because it
doesn't make sense they'll be private
clouds for you know have all the benefit
of the cloud but they just don't have
you know infinite expansion and then
they'll be public clouds and you're
going to have to connect them and be
secure and that's what took us down the
path with red hat that belief the
structure of that is fundamentally
different than something that's consumer
facing so the the lesson you learn there
is you can't just reuse something that
that's optimized for consumers very
interesting point doesn't mean consumer
companies can't move up into the
Enterprise because obviously they have
right but I think it's very hard to take
something from the Enterprise and come
on down because it got to be simple
consumable all the things we talked
about already plus you have to have the
relationships with Enterprise yeah very
different yeah I mean you know our
history right at one time we had the PC
business and you know the short answer
to why would we would not do that is
it's a consumer-facing business we were
good at the Enterprise and that consumer
business a highly competitive got to be
low cost all the things that are not the
same muscles necessarily of being in an
innovation driven you know uh technology
business yeah but what is now Lenovo I
guess that's what it's just been done we
are extremely good at that so but not as
good as you're saying is it at an
Enterprise or it's not it was it was
almost very good at their PC World yes
but I wouldn't and they can sell into
the Enterprise yeah right but you as a
consumer can go buy a Lenovo too so look
at look in China right look in other
places so that's what I mean consumer
you know an end device and that was a
big decision because it would have been
one of the last things that had our logo
on it that sits in your hands right so
when a new generation says what does IBM
do right was that a difficult decision
this is a long time ago now it's like
2005. yeah so um
they're all difficult because it's not
only things as people
um but it's back to knowing who you are
is how I would sum that up as right and
we were never great at making a lot of
money at that and you can remember
provision is Abby NPC than there were
IBM clones or you they even called IBM
clones back then
um as the field became highly highly
competitive and as things commoditized
we often as they commoditize we would
move them out and move on to the next
Innovation level
but because of that it's not as
public-facing
recognizable logos ever yeah isn't it
true that is very true that is actually
a very important point and that is
you know branding as you say one of the
most recognizable in a very highly
ranked brand strength around the world
and so
that's a trade-off I mean I can't you
know it because there was a time you'd
have something of IBM in your home or
right or a cash register as an example
you'd walk into a store actually they're
still in places that went to Toshiba